[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
steve palazzolo joining us on loan from
pro football focus their senior analyst
and host of
pff nfl podcast they have put out their
rankings
the top receiving core in the nfl all
right give me the rationale before
we do the top five here steve yeah so
when it comes to receiving course i
think in today's
nfl you got to look at the top three
receivers you get so you have to look at
depth and you also have to look at the
tight end so most of the negative
feedback i get is
people throwing their best wide receiver
duo at me what about these what about
these two but it's all about
depth having the three legitimate
threats or four legitimate threats
in today's nfl and i think you know some
of these best teams are just really deep
when it comes to pascal
but what about the one the running back
who is a pass catcher as well did you
factor that in a little bit here and
there this was
this particular write-up was just
receivers and tight ends and running
back receivers they're nice to have
but their receptions in general are a
little bit less valuable than receivers
and tight ends anyway
okay let's start at number five the five
number five on your list best receiving
core is
it's the tennessee titans and the best
part about this is when i first did this
list a few months ago they were in like
the late
high 20s because it was aj brown and
then a whole bunch of question marks but
having julio jones added to the mix here
as much as i was just preaching depth if
you do have two elite players it does
offset things a little bit
and then anthony ferkser is a he's a
really good shifty good route riding
tight end who i think is going to have a
big year for the titans
okay number four on the list is who do
we have here the buffalo bills they're
the classic team
when it comes to depth because what
they've done
with josh allen is gone from zero
receivers to then they added cole
beasley and they added john brown
john brown's out now and it's emanuel
sanders so you've got two good receivers
there
and then stefan diggs and they've all
got pretty
distinct roles emmanuel sanders knows
how to get open
cole beasley gets open from the slot and
then staphon digs can do it all it can
be a deep threat intermediate threat so
three legitimate receivers dawson knox
is a pretty good tight end as well but i
just really love the bill's depth at
wide receiver
because that trio is as good as it gets
around the nfl where is stefan diggs on
the individual
list of best wide receivers in football
there's so many good receivers in the
nfl
right now so if you say top 10 it's not
like a knock on him but you know last
year he's probably a top five guy
i think year in year out you could count
on him being a top 10 type of receiver
because he does it all well
uh route running the most important
thing a receiver can do is get open
right pretty simple stuff but stefan
diggs is one of the best in the league
at doing that
all right number three on your list so
it's the kansas city chiefs and this is
where maybe the depth hurt them just a
little bit because
nobody compares to tyree kill and travis
kelsey those guys
uh they're i don't want to say they're
uncoverable we just saw them get pretty
well covered in the super bowl but
they are the most dangerous combination
tiring kill legitimate deep threat
if you just made him a slot receiver you
catch 150 passes
and then tyrion travis kelsey you know
the best receiving tight end in the nfl
the big question is that number three
spot who's the third receiver
you know sammy watkins is out mikol
hardman has done some nice things
uh drafted a couple players at receiver
in tight end last year so that's going
to be the big thing for the chiefs is
having that third
option emerge and that's what really did
hurt them in the super bowl is not
having
a third receiver when the defense was
just focused on tyree kill and travis
kelsey well it also hurt they didn't
have a good offensive line in the super
bowl
also that too all right and and that
line is so much better
where does kansas city's line rank among
other nfl teams right now going into uh
camp so they're in the top ten you know
i think i had him seventh in our
offensive line rankings and let's not
let's not have revisionist history here
the 2020 kansas city chiefs had a good
offensive line
the 2020 super bowl chiefs had a
terrible offensive line because they all
got heard and they moved mike remembers
from right top to left tackle
the chiefs have had a good offensive
line in all three years that patrick
mahomes has been starter
it just completely fell apart in that
one game and they've done a really good
job of adding depth and good starters in
this offseason
all right number two on uh your list of
best receiving cores
so i'm going with the dallas cowboys
another team that uh
the three deep at receiver is just
incredible amari cooper is a legitimate
number one
uh excellent route runner uh gets open
at the short and intermediate
level really well adds cd lam to the mix
and then michael gallup so michael
gallup has been a really good number two
during his time there cd lam has a
chance to be another number one so amari
cooper is a one
cd lamb is a one gallop is a two that
trio
is excellent i think we're going to see
cd lamb stealing a whole bunch
more targets this year um and and i
really think the cowboys you know as far
as that trio much like the bills
uh is as good as it gets around the nfl
where's the cowboys
defense rank now that is a tough
question because last year they were
horrible
it was a new system a new scheme you
could tell they were all over the place
uh busted coverages like crazy having
dan quinn come in
should handle some of that you know it's
just it's a simpler system
but there's no way you could say that
they project to be a top half of the
league defense just because
they just haven't done it the last
couple years so i'd say bottom half of
the league defense where
maybe there's a little bit more
stability with dan quinn coming in with
a simpler scheme based off what they
played
with last year so number one on your
list the the team that has the best core
of receivers has to be the tampa bay
bucks right i mean this is ridiculous
with mike evans chris godwin
antonio brown that trio uh even antonio
brown at this point in his career
we saw what he did um i love scotty
miller even though he has a very
specific role just
run deep scotty go run 4-2 down the
field tommy hits him down the field all
the time
and then that the tight ends rob
gronkowski oj howard coming back off
injury cameron breit
there's nothing in the league like it
and we saw last year even when guys got
hurt o.j howard got hurt
antonio brown missed a playoff game mike
evans missed time
they had enough depth to to make up for
it and again that is how you win in
today's nfl you stretch the field
with guys who are difficult to cover if
you're a defense how do you handle
all of those players how do you handle
and cover all of those receivers in
tight ends it's it's really difficult to
do uh
the bucks offense or defense ranked
higher around the league
i'd say definitely the offense i thought
the defense was good last year again
it's not let's not completely overrate
that one performance in the super bowl
they were awesome in the super bowl they
had
other performances like that last year
but they were good not great
offense in tampa bay though especially
after the buy last week they were great
and they have a potential to be great
once again
the uh bottom two receiving cores in the
nfl
so the detroit lions have to be down
there because we just you know they've
re
they've overhauled everything uh tyrell
williams looks like they're number one
he's a good player but you know he's
he's a two or
three type of receiver and then the
houston texans especially brandon cook's
rumored to maybe be on the trading block
he's their only legitimate threat so
they have a whole bunch of
solid threats but texans lions they're
not scaring anybody with their receivers
and tight ends at this point
would you advise the texans to trade
deshawn watson
i think at this point they they might
have to i wouldn't really advise it i
mean
i don't know what's happening off the
field obviously and i don't even know
what's happening with their relationship
if they could mends the relationship i
would keep desean watson i mean he is
as a player a top five top three asset
in the nfl right now as far as
what he's going to bring from a value
standpoint on the field
so if you can keep them around i think
that's the best option if not you better
get
three four five first rounders for them
uh because your your whole team is
starting to get overhauled which
already looks like it's happening in
houston anyway if you were going to make
the the call
for the new orleans saints quarterback
position
jameis winston taysom hill with if
michael thomas is healthy when he's
on the field i would always lean jameis
i'm a james guy i think he's got some
volatility to his game
that you can harness and you can move
the ball and you just have to deal with
some turnovers and all that stuff
i'm scared i mean you who are the worst
receiving course if i take michael
thomas out of the equation
the saints are the worst they're now 32
if michael thomas is hurt
for an extended period of time and
because of that i might lean taysom hill
i might say you know what
we're going to run the ball a ton taysom
hill is going to be a run threat he's
going to carry the ball 10 to 12 times a
game that might be the only way the
saints can win
because it's marquez callaway and
treycon smith and
adam troutman that's their group of
playmakers they might need to be a run
first type of team with jason hill
always great to talk to you steve thank
you for joining us thanks dan appreciate
it steve palazzolo the
pro football focus senior analyst host
of pff
nfl podcast